c'était donc maurice audin la
disparition un documentaire signé
françois demerliac alors pour en parler
pour évoquer ce drame pour évoquer la
torture en algérie l'attitude de l'armée
du gouvernement france du gouvernement
français du fln pour voir dans quelles
conditions ce passé douloureux cette
déchirure pourrait prendre place de
façon un peu plus apaisé moins
passionnel dans notre histoire est bien
autour de cette table sylvie thénault
bonsoir on insère coréenne spécialisée
de ces de cette période et ces
questions-là de la torture en général et
des exactions des états que je puis dire
en particulier de la répression et de la
répression en particulier
maurice faivre et henri pouillot alors
oui ça vous avez des documents gens
montrent plusieurs puisque vous êtes si
tu es dans ce livre de jean charge aux
frais sur ses officiers qui ont dit non
à la torture et vous avez créé vous même
le renseignement dans la guerre
d'algérie parce que vous êtes générale
aujourd'hui vous avez fini votre
carrière comme général mais j'étais un
spécialiste du renseignement puisque
j'ai terminé comme commandant le
deuxième bureau baden et strasbourg donc
j'étais un spécialiste du renseignement
militaire
bon il pendant la guerre va dézinguer un
officier la guerre d'algérie voilà
j'étais lieutenant puis capitaine tu
fais de chedjou pendant votre séjour et
vous étiez un militaire d' active et
engagée
j'étais à côté de vous donc henri
pouillot vous vous êtes un militaire un
ancien militaire aussi mais vous étiez à
naples et dans une pop amis tels retient
appelé et vous avez participé à cette
guerre d'algérie et dès votre arrivée
vous êtes vous a été affecté à la villa
susini vous le racontez dans ce livre
c'est ça et vous avez témoigné de ce que
vous avez pu y faire et de ce que vous
avez pu voir dans cette villa susini qui
était un centre de torture en fait aller
si c'est d'ailleurs le seul centre de
torture qui fonctionne toute la guerre
d'algérie alger et u21 j'ai eu un
certain nombre de centres corruptives
plus épisodique vilain c'est génial
cette crise ce serait triste privilège
et s'énerve et et vous y avez fait tout
votre service n'ont pas tous nos séances
neuf mois seulement
ap neuf mois seulement ce qui est déjà
un enfer terrible bon mais votre
découverte de la guerre du service de
soldats ça a été ça
en fait le joueur turc s'est
effectivement ça c'est cette douloureuse
période qui laisse des traces très
profonde
bon alors on va parler de ça de votre
témoignage et nous rejoindrons tout à
l'heure malika rahal qui elle est
historienne et qui va parler d'une idée
comparable à celle de maurice audin en
fin d'une histoire pardon d'un drame
comparable à celui de maurice audin et
puis charles silvestre qui lui aussi a
fait son service militaire en algérie et
qui est ancien journaliste toujours et
je crois à l'humanité et qui est à
l'origine de ce qu'on appelait l'appel
des douze d'abord avec vous françois
demerliac vous êtes réalisateur
vous n'êtes pas spécialiste au départ de
ces questions de l'algérie de cette
période la torture non non non au départ
non moi je réalisais à à vous intéresser
à ça ce qui m'a amené bon moi j'ai
travaillé sur d'autres sujets ce qui
touche à la colonisation de la
décolonisation j'ai travaillé par
exemple pour la cité des sciences sur
l'histoire de la médecine et de la
colonisation enfin bon et en fait
j'avais travaillé aussi sur un film sur
sartre en fait mon intérêt pour le sujet
il vient de plusieurs plusieurs ce que
j'ai lu il ya plusieurs de facebook que
vous vouliez faire voilà on a rencontré
madame aude a alors qui m'amène à
rencontrer mal à mouiller votre et en
coexistence dans votre immeuble avec
vidal naquet ce que vous étiez un voisin
de palier peut pas de palier mais disons
que vitrine habitaient dans la même
maison donc moi quand j'étais gamin je
vous le croisez régulièrement voilà donc
et puis c'était une personnalité quand
même un peu pas donc votre soeur votre
histoire vos amis sur le chemin de ces
gens là voilà voilà
absolument voilà bon et j'avais donc
rencontré madame aude à l avait jamais
parlé
elle avait parlé mais elle avait parlé à
travers des écrits à travers des
articles elle a toujours eu une activité
très insistante disons sur la question
de la reconnaissance de la torture et en
particulier autour de la disparition de
son mari est en fait sur le 1er
interview j'avais fait d'elle ce qui
était d'ailleurs difficile parce qu'au
départ elle voulait pas parler elle
voulait elle avait quelques
appréhensions c'est une personne très
pudique donc l'idée de passer devant une
caméra était quelque chose qui était un
petit peu difficile pour elle mais bon
je vais réussi à la halle à convaincre
je vais dit que j'étais quand même
l'occasion de parler de l'histoire de
son mari de cette disparition et que
peut-être que le fait de pouvoir en
parler d'une façon peut-être un peu plus
large en utilisant les médias était une
façon on ne l'espérait un peu pour un
lac de lait avec vous ce qu'elle est
peut-être refusé avec d'autres à je ne
sais pas si elle a refusé avec d'autres
je sais qu'elle l'a acceptée avec moi
donc voilà bon et après en fait lors de
cette première interview elle a dit face
à la caméra
ce serait bien qu'ils aient un film qui
soit fait sur la disparition de mon mari
est sûre l'affairé rodin on va très vite
et écouter justement dans votre
documentaire comment elle raconte déjà
l'arrestation de son mari
c'était donc le 11 juin 157 nous venions
nous coucher il devait être onze heures
du soir
quand on a entendu tambouriner à la
porte
c'étaient les parachutistes qui est
arrivé en
en nombre d hommes ils étaient très
nombreux certains sont repartis avec mon
mari en emmenant mon mari et d'autres
sont restés dans l'appartement
j'ai demandé donc au capitaine de vis où
ils ont emmené mon mari quand est ce
qu'il a dit revenir et le capitaine de
wismes a répondu s'il est raisonnable
il sera là dans une
voilà c'est là que henri alleg est venue
le lendemain de l'arrestation de mon
mari allait très touchante à cette femme
est toujours dans sa façon de s'exprimer
dans cette façon de fermer les yeux pour
aller chercher peut-être à l'intérieur
d'elle-même les souvenirs qu'est l'axone
de cette époque qu'est ce que vous
garder d'elle non c'est quelqu'un de
bouquets beaucoup de courage parce que
enfin d'une part arrivé 1
enfin c'est pas la même forme que
courage de courage que celle de vidal
naquet qui lui s'est exposé qui est un
militant qui est un militant qui a payé
physiquement aussi de son engagement
lll va au delà de sa propre pudeur en
fait c'était ça aussi qui était
difficile lors de l'interview avec elle
qui a duré quand même assez longtemps
parce qu il l était toujours à vouloir
continuer à voir ce cas trop les suivre
à se contrôler dire les choses aller au
bout de ce qu'elle avait à dire alors
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'elle attend
aujourd'hui près de 50 ans après 50 ans
a passé de résoudre à mla elle a fait
une lettre ouverte représente un public
acquis à sa fille elle-même a refusé une
opération onze ces raisons là qu'est ce
qu'elle attend vraiment c'est quoi son
choix qu'elle attend deux choses d'une
part avoir la réponse
où est son mari la réponse officielle
enfin la réponse officielle où la
réponse des acteurs disons de des faits
et c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'est devenu
maurice audin où est son corps qu'est ce
qui s'est passé sur donc savoir la
vérité sur ce qui s'est passé ça c'est
une chose
et puis l'autre chose c'est avoir une
reconnaissance officielle de l'état
français sur la torture sur la
disparition de son mari mais qui est un
des milliers de disparus de la guerre
d'algérie s'est pas seulement maurice
audin brisseau d'un disons qu'il a été
du fait de sa
c'était un intellectuel enfin bon c'est
dit par d'autres dans le film c'était
donc une personne exemplaire de quelque
chose qui était pratiqué à très très
large échelle façon notre échec mais les
chaînes on va en parler d'un instant et
vos oeufs / dernière chose sur votre
film l'attitude des autorités militaires
officielles actuelles françaises
j'imagine que vous êtes allé les
solliciter quand vous les fait ce film
moi j'ai surtout essayé de solliciter
les acteurs c'est-à-dire aux
particuliers ou serait ce qu'un homo
enfin le ceux qui sont cités dans sa
fille donc le responsable des
renseignements militaires pendant la
bataille d'alger so lu ment donc elle
refuse et qui a confessé un d'avoir
particulier abondamment la torture yaniv
a confessé mais bon il a confessé
c'était en 2008
voilà donc une arme mais dit-on 2000 ou
2001 adressé ses plus beaux moments de
notre action lundi et donc mais vous
vouliez cette parole là voulait parler
de l'état français paie des militaires
siècle c'était intéressant de voir la
réponse des français militaires qui
avaient participé à ça d'accord bon donc
aussaresses qui était quand même un des
militaires officielles faits divers deux
attachés à cette histoire c'est dire et
dont la pleine responsabilité était
engagée sur la sphère odin messieurs
aussi sur la sphère de l'ibu mendjel
enfin voix sur pluzz bon lui a refusé
d'accord plus homo a refusé et les
autorités actuelles en fait les
autorités alors en revanche là où j'ai
eu un bon accueil c'est un de ces pcr
que au fait que j'avais besoin de
documents établissements publics et
sylvette à glasgow voilà donc un gros
coup d'archivés archives que j'ai
utilisé des verts eelv auront payé
d'avoir seize cela ces archives la
audiovisuels ont été extraits simple
mais bon il ya un certain nombre
d'autres archives qui malheureusement
que sont pas d'accord aussi alors parce
que si on voit bien on voit bien dans
votre film que vous faites le
le relais de la thèse de la thyroïde de
vidal naquet sur la façon avec laquelle
on a comment dire habillé sa disparition
je puis dire transformer une exécution
éventuellement en disparition vos énéral
vous dites ça c'est qu'une thèse ya pas
de preuves on sait pas will be done
lequel d'une part pour moi ce n'est pas
un historien de l'algérie il le dit
lui-même dans un colloque qui a eu lieu
à nancy ya quelques années dit je ne
suis pas un historien de l'algérie c'est
un spécialiste de l'histoire grecque
alors là je lui ai tiré au chapeau il
est très qualifié ce risque grec mans
mais sur l'histoire d'algérie c'est un
militant c'est un agitateur c'est tout
ce que vous voulez mais il a il a fait
des hypothèses sur cette histoire
d'enlèvement mais sans arriver à aucune
preuve et aucune preuve
il ya par les mavs aujourd'hui c'est la
conviction dont je crois qu'il ya pas de
preuve dans le film juste que je trouve
c'est que on parle beaucoup de la tête
de vidal naquet mais on oublie de parler
de toutes les enquêtes qui ont été
menées il ya eu des enquêtes de
gendarmerie il ya eu des enquêtes faites
par les procureurs militaires
il ya eu des gens qui est faite par la
commission de sauvegarde du droit et de
la liberté sa boule ignorait
complètement
et oui oui le nuage les sites
excusez-moi de vous interrompre mais
d'une part les hypothèses de vie dans
laquelle j'avais été contredite
officiellement par qui que ce soit
d'autre part j'ai fait des recherches si
elle est au centre de l'histoire de
sciences po il ya un certain nombre de
documents tous les éléments de la
procédure au fait qu'ils aient recoupent
très exactement se vend au mot près le
livre de vidal naquet sont là ils sont
accessibles disponibles on a le rapport
bas vous à l'eau on a le rapport de l'
enquête de police qui arrivait à vie est
rigoureusement qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
t'arrive m
vois moi moi je je suis d'accord avec la
thèse de la commission de sauvegarde le
monsieur doria il y avait dans la
commission de sauvegarde quand même des
gens très très éminent les professeurs
richelle professeur de vers le gist le
recteur d'or que j'ai sur le son garde
du droit et des libertés qui avait été
créée par guy mollet en mai ils ont dit
croire dans cette commission
eh bien ils ont fait ils ont fait une
enquête on fait une recherche il en dit
long dit il ya une disparition c'est
troublant nous on n'a pas de preuves
voilà voilà la conclusion on en reste là
c'est la thèse officielle et vous
et puis ensuite c'était quand même
soumis au jugement et la commission de
la cour de cassation a rejeté le pourvoi
que lui avait adressé mal de mode a
conservé le banc l'histoire l'histoire
était celle à terminer devant la
victoire se termine lundi d'historienne
son histoire
l'historienne s'inscrit en faux de a à z
avec ce qui vient d'être dit il n'y a
pas besoin d'être un spécialiste de
l'algérie pour écrire un livre comme
celui que vidal naquet écrit qu'est
celui ci l'a fait rodin et c'est un
livre dans lequel en fait il met ses
compétences d'historiens critique des
sources
et c'est sa capacité à critiquer les
sourcils à travailler sur des écrits
qu'ils mettent en oeuvre
c'est pas question d'être spécialiste de
l'algérie bien deuxièmement je suis très
stupéfaite par la régression du débat
alors la régression du débat c'est dire
que ce livre là en général aux seules
questions là oui aujourd'hui en
particulier ce livre là elle est sorti
en 1958
lisez le vraiment j'appelle tout le
monde à lui lire tous les documents dont
parle maurice faivre
ils sont cités ya un nombre d'éléments
nombreux et je trouve que c'est vraiment
une régression aujourd'hui que de venir
dire que c'est une thèse qu'il y en a
d'autres
boudu con pour rire voilà qu'on rien en
cause aujourd'hui des choses qu'on
considérait comme plus ou moins acquis
il ya bien quelques années moi je suis
stupéfaite y compris lisez le monde
de l'année 1957 pour un historien lire
le monde de l'année 1957 c'est une mine
d'or pas tous tirés mais vous avez à
partir du printemps 1957 une déferlante
d'affaires il y à la sphère ali
boumendjel notamment qui prouve quoi qui
prouve qu'à alger depuis que les
parachutistes ont obtenu les pouvoirs de
police
ils arrêtent en masse sans déclarer leur
arrestation et de la sorte il ya des
disparitions où il y a des gens dont on
dit qu'ils se sont suicidés alors qu'on
n'a aucune preuve de leur sens réel
concernant maurice audin il est arrêté
le 12 juin
son arrestation n'est officiellement
réclame déclaré que le 21 il ya neuf
jours pendant lesquels cet homme a été
détenu par les paras chez l'européen si
je comprends bien aux dix ans qui s'est
évadé ça pas tout de suite non il est
d'abord il y avait le système qui était
en place et qu'il y avait à la
préfecture d'alger
un secrétaire général qui s'appelait
paul t jane qui étaient chargés
normalement de recevoir de la part des
militaires la déclaration leur
arrestation
l'idée était de pouvoir quand même un
peu contrôlées qui étaient arrêtés ou
intelligent donner les clés de la ville
et de la répression en général massu en
janvier 1957 on a donné les pouvoirs de
police au général massu c'est à dire les
pouvoirs d'arrestation de détention et
d'interrogatoire et devait rendre compte
2 minimum en ti au pouvoir civil voilà
épaules des deux jeunes qui était lui
secrétaire général de la préfecture
d'alger devait recevoir des comptes
rendus des arrestations effectuées et
signer des arrêtés qui les officialiser
cet homme là a fini par démissionner
parce qu'il s'est aperçu qu'il n'était
pas informé de toutes les arrestations
qu'il y avait des gens dont on ne savait
jamais ce qu'ils devenaient y compris
dans la sphère ou d'un on vient
l'avertir neuf jours après de
l'arrestation d'une personne donc c'est
dans ce problème là c'est de là que
vient la fée road 1 c'est bon vouloir
exactement des pouvoirs qu'on a donnés
aux militaires alors et du déficit de
contrôle sur ce qu'il faisait en réalité
et ça c'est pas une thèse de ville
un hacker ça c'est la vérité de vous
parliez de la sphère l'ibu mendjel on va
en parler de salaire avec malika rahal
mais pour qu'on comprenne bien ça
concerne combien de personnes nues
combien de disparition de ce type est ce
qu'on sait ce qu'a représenté vous me
direz ça fait longtemps qu'on le sait
mais pour les gens qu'ils auraient pas
que ça concerne comme une personne la
torture en algérie et les morts ou les
disparitions de sony pas en algérie
c'est une question à laquelle on ne peut
pas répondre parce que comme je viens de
vous le dire
la comptabilité des départs abondé dans
la ville était exactement donc comment
voulez vous qu'on sache aujourd'hui
combien il y en avait et ça c'est un
débat que quelque part je trouve
relativement pervers parce que
l'exigence de chiffres elle nous conduit
sous la pression et éventuellement en
produire mais on sait très bien qu'ils
sont fragiles
donc en fait qu'on la voit début de la
révision
exactement enfin oui c'est à dire que on
ouvre la voie à des gens qui vous disent
mais sur quoi repose vos chiffres là
hein
il ne repose sur rien donc qu'est ce
qu'il s'est vraiment passé
peut-être rien et donc c'est pour cette
raison que moi dans mes travaux sur la
répression
j'insiste toujours sur la nécessité de
reconstituer le système répressif en
place est de montrer que parce que
précisément il repose sur un déficit du
contrôle des arrestations effectuées
tout est possible tel que par exemple
pour revenir à cette affaire rodin on
voit dans votre film vous vous faites
une reconstitution de ce qu'aurait pu
être le simulacre d'évasion a organisé
par l'armée pour dissimuler une
exécution à partir des témoignages
précise cet appareil de témoigner à
partir des témoignages à partir des
rapports des procès verbaux à la fois au
départ des militaires ensuite des
policiers enfin des différents
témoignages pour montrer les
contradictions successives qui ont
abouti à l'hypothèse de pierre vidal
naquet qui essayait de de faire quoi si
la louve et message politique que vous
allez faire imaginer à trouver une thèse
qui colle avec tous et distorsions là
les premières thèses les premières
thèses était totalement absurde si vous
voulez donc après il fallait trouver une
explication à l'absurdité
donc par rapport à ça en essayant de
croiser les différentes hypothèses
et puis les contradictions des
militaires parce que charbonnier en fait
au fil du temps est revenu sur son
premier témoignage parce qu'il s'est
rendu compte que ça tenait pas la route
cyr il a dit des choses qui bon kiki qui
est épais comme s'ouvrir aux locales et
d'associations eu des malins relais sur
des choses on se rend compte
effectivement qu'on prête flanc à la
critique parce que ce n'est pas crédible
parce que c'est pas très vite
ah c'était ça donc il a croisé ces
différents témoignages ceux des
militaires ceux des autres témoins comme
le dock terme le docteur mairesse qui
étaient là parce qu'il habitait dans le
quartier
donc il ya vu une ombre bon et par
rapport à tous ces témoignages qui sait
il a réfléchi avec l'inde ont inquiété
le l'éditeur de désinhibition de minuit
qui a collaboré d'ailleurs au texte la
faire ou d'un et il est arrivé à la
conclusion de son hypothèse mais ça
n'était qu'une hypothèse c'est juste que
je suis c'est une hypothèse
dans sa démonstration si je peux me
permettre
il y à un premier temps qui est avéré
est incontestable c'est que cette
évasion n'a jamais eu lieu et qu'elle a
été jouée pour camoufler la mort de
maurice audin et le véritable problème
ce qui est toujours la souffrance de la
famille odin aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ne
sait pas ensuite ce qu'a toujours
défendu pierre vidal naquet sur la foi
du témoignage du commissaire central de
la ville d'alger jambes d'huile c'est
que le lieutenant charbonnier a étranglé
maurice audin au cours d'une séance de
torture sous le coup d'un accès de
colère mais c'est très difficile de
confirmer que ce fait là est juste parce
que ça repose sur ce témoignage
et voilà le problème que l'on rencontre
c'est que plus le temps s'éloigne plus
les difficile de savoir la vérité
alors j'ai on va voir un autre extrait
du documentaire puisque la ja
témoignages qui est pas réfutable
sociale csu le témoin jean ray allen qui
a donc croisé
maurice audin pendant sa détention et il
ya vu dans quel état il était et qui a
constaté comment la torture elle était
avérée
on écoute quand je suis arrivé le
policier qui m'a ouvert la porte
je n'ai pas eu besoin qui se présente
pour savoir tout de suite que c'était un
inspecteur entre est rentré ses rentrées
et immédiatement il a téléphoné au au pc
des parachutistes en disant rapidement
qu'il fallait qu'ils viennent quoi ils
sont venus le lieutenant il m'a
évidemment immédiatement reconnu
j'étais sur la liste de ce qu'on
cherchait il à dire assez c'est henri
alleg excellent prix iddy c'est le le
directeur d alger républicain et puis
tout de suite il me demande où est ce
que vous êtes et bergers il vous le
dirais pas je racontais tout ça dans la
question dans la voiture donc qui
m'emmenait je savais déjà ce qui
m'attendait quoi effectivement je crois
même pas une heure après j'étais sur la
plancha torture et ça commençait pour
moi voilà il était maçon qui sont durs
en tendant la plancha torture presque
dialectes berbères si nous avoir
rejoints disais que vous étiez vous même
vous avez été en algérie comme appelez
vous avez je sais pas ce que lui à
connaître vous même de la torture quand
vous y étiez non mais on en parlait oui
bien sûr je visais l'express takoré dans
l'express sur des serveurs fumeurs qui
écrit lauriac qui disait des choses
fortes sur la question et hurler que je
ne parvenais en algérie vous l'aviez
vous dans les limites et vous l'aviez
dit ya des quelques librairies on
pouvait trouver l'expérience et c'est
compliqué l'histoire de billy cabral
il ya des militaires des officiers qui
me demandent l express pour lire ce qui
suit publier ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils
partageaient le produit l'express
mais ils voulaient savoir ce qui se
disait on le savait on en parlait on
s'en inquiétait certains militaires s'en
offusquer non non non non la vue
il y avait ce que je voulais dire tout à
l'heure vous écoutant il ya eu toujours
tout tout du long de la guerre d'algérie
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il ya eu ce qu'on
appelle une omerta militaire il ya des
choses qui se fondent dont on ne parle
pas voilà ça je sais pas combien ce que
sont fermes au sol niveau de désaccord
avec ces choses-là
oui tout à fait tout à fait je parle des
militaires d'activé débilité responsable
chez eux à pied sa trame appelé en
algérie bien sûr on sait bien ce qui
s'est passé en 61 puisque les appeler au
se sont levés contre le putsch avant
d'enlever céline des raisons avec
l'appel du général de gaulle de chaque
poule est foutu alors revenons se
voulait bien avec vous notamment henri
pouillot sur ce qu'était la torture
parce que vous vous étiez à naples et je
sais pas comment appeler se retrouve
dans un centre de torture moi je connais
pas mais moi je pensais c'était quand
même plutôt pour des militaires un peu
triés sur le volet quoi si je puis dire
on pouvait être à plein se retrouver là
au comptant de la torture au début de la
guerre d'algérie à mon avis il n'y a pas
eu d'appeler qui a été dans les centres
de torture c'est qu'un vers la fin de la
guerre d'algérie que l'armée incorporer
des appelés dans les centres de torture
moi j'ai été infectés laissant torture
des plats partout il y en a à tous les
coins de rue où il avait généré un
certain nombre même la période de la fin
de la guerre d'algérie vous étaient les
neuf derniers mois j'étais ya ne veut
plus commun accord plusieurs albums
entièrement d'accord moi ce que je
voudrais quand même évoqué la souffrance
que j'ai depuis cette tête bike est
toujours vivace et elle est profonde
j'ai vu avec un handicap en fait c'est
un peu comme ça que je le ressens et je
trouve que c'est un peu dérangeante les
débats qu'on a sur cette guerre
d'algérie on va être à 50 ans de la fin
de la guerre d'algérie et aujourd'hui on
n'évoque pas le problème qui ne sont
fondamentales c'est de reconnaître et de
condamner tous les crimes contre
l'humanité les crimes d'état qui ont été
commis pendant cette guerre d'algérie je
trouve que c'est on a eu dont on a vu
des tortures des viols d
villages rasés au napalm des crevettes
bigeard et autres aspects ça s'est
toujours pas reconnu comme dtn du contre
l'humanité toujours pas condamné
quand la france se dit le pays des
droits de l'homme et qu'on laisse faire
ces aspects je dis non c'est pas
acceptable
ce film de maurice audin doit permettre
justement d'être un poids sur lequel on
on à la véracité de la torture comme
quelque chose de dieu et qu'on allait la
tuer et je voudrais dire deuxième
souffrance pour vous aujourd'hui ça
qu'on n'ait pas reconnu ces landais
mental mais vous avez été témoin de quoi
vous sur le terrain ça se passe et
comment alors j'étais de plus affectés
aux aspects administratifs de cette
ville un la gestion des fichiers qui
aidera les cantons comme ceux ci lui dit
tout à l'heure par rapport aux archives
il y avait eu lors de trois mille 3000
fiche dans la villa susini quand je suis
parti le 13 mars 62 g hulot au téléphone
le fichier qu'avec un an et qui nous a
remplacé la bise à tigo il m'a dit mais
ne veut pas témoigner parce que c'est un
officier d'activ il veut pas le
confirmer
les fichiers ont été éparpillés dans le
jardin de la villa surtout vous gériez
administrativement les entrées et
sorties de cette ville là est-ce que
vous avez assisté ou entendu ou vu des
choses précises avec notamment parce que
on était une petite unité de ton sang
j'étais appelé à donner un coup de main
je ne sais pas comment le dire le terme
et est choquant mais a participé dans
les salles de torture de delà de la
ville un jeu vous appréhendez vient bien
toi c'était pas possible de s'en
échapper
j'étais comme dans le livre que je dis
je t'ai comme dans une prison sans
barreau
je n'avais pas de deux
deux relais extérieurs enfin la page
était pas militant j'ai découvert toutes
ces questions on a avec la garde avec le
tir du policier terre j'avais pas de
donner le coup de main c'était quoi
mais c'était donner un coup de main pour
attacher la personne sur la table de
torture c'était c'était prendre les
notes de thé des choses qui était dit
dans les interrogatoires que comme
monsieur favre dit interrogatoires et
veut pas dire torture tisser zen à coups
de butoir à coups de coin villa est il y
avait le lot et que tu utilisé et l
électricité en algérie à ce moment là
c'était du 110 volts c'est manu 220 et
on utilisait les prises électriques car
lens ça vous avez vu ça ben oui mais m
et on voit si je crois vous dit quelque
part on sait pas qu'on s'y habitue mais
c'est presque normal quoi
quand on est dedans on retient guillou
pas et sillage m enfin je n'ai pas dû
dire ça on ne peut pas s'habituer
c'était un traumatisme encore
aujourd'hui j'ai encore des cauchemars
sur ces questions de ce que j'ai vécu
dans cette spéciale on est on veut
oublier comme tous les militaires on a
voulu oublier tout ce que tous l'enfer
qu'on a vécu mais on peut pas l'oublier
c'est c'est quelque chose qui reste
enraciné cocon garde à vue l'enjeu du
ray est ce qu'à un moment vous dit c'est
pas possible on peut pas faire ça on n'a
pas le droit de faire ça ce que vous
dites à vos supérieurs à ce que vous
dites
parce qu'à un moment vous vous rebeller
ou est-ce que c'est pas possible de se
rebeller c'est ça c'est pas possible de
se rebeller
qu'est ce que je pouvais faire je me
rebeller et shalio prison militaire
j'avais un jeu parvenait mais il faut
replacer dans le contexte des
communications de l'époque on pouvait
pas téléphoner écrire que et il n'y
avait pas internet etc
on pouvait pas communiquer comme on peut
le faire aujourd'hui les choses sont
totalement différentes se révéler ça
voulait dire
soit je crie tel j'ai déserté sur place
où aller où je n'avais pas de repères
sur un visage et j'allais vers le fln en
disant je n'ai à la ville de la villette
unis c'était de me faire me suicider on
veut pas dire à vos supérieurs je peux
plus je peux pas c'est trop je veux être
envoyés ailleurs dans d'autres unités
pour faire autre chose c'est pas dans
les contextes de de subordination dans
lesquelles les gens étaient sur place
c'était beau c'était quasiment pas
possible de faire de se révéler sur
cette question aujourd'hui ce qui est ni
plus ni moins que d'être victime d'une
corvée doigt comme comme les autres
général avait en colère à la fois
blessés et peut-être même honteux
d'avoir assisté à ça et que personne ne
vienne là vous l'avez entre guillemets
de ce que vous avez vu l'ambiance est un
exemple concret près de sortie de
l'algérie quand j'étais allons allons
j'ai essayé de décrire un document pour
faire dire ce que j'avais vécu là bas je
n'ai discuté avec les appeler yann
officiers de la sécurité militaire qui
est venu enquêter dans le résumé pour
tenter de récupérer ces documents
parce que même après la guerre d'avion
ne peuvent pas s'exprimer sur ces
questions
c'était ça restait dangereux alors sous
terre quand même
vous voulez quoi aujourd'hui vous voulez
vous attendez quoi parce que j'ai tout
bien savent anniversaire justement
j'avais donné le deuxième essai des
accords d'evian qu'est ce qu'il attend
de vous que nous avons aujourd'hui il ya
quatre militaires qui savent comment
maurice audin est mort exactement dix
ans qu'on avait disparu il ya mauritius
sweet qui était présent aux services de
renseignement dans cette période qu'il
est encore vivant qui était encore
vivant et qui elle qui a été accusé à de
nombreuses reprises d'avoir fait un don
vous pensez qu'ils savent ce que je
pense je suis certain qu'ils le fil si
mauvais
générac était très proche qui est
toujours très proche de maurice schmitt
je pense que comme officier de
renseignement il peut pas nous fait
savoir un certain nombre de choses plus
précise que ce qu'il a osé a accepté de
dire aujourd'hui il ya surtout le
capitaine
la bourdonnais montluc qui a pris la
succession 2 avait ce qui dans le livre
de marie monique robin est dans le livre
du général heureuse à lens a donné un
certain nombre d'éléments
vous voudriez quoique ces militaires là
dont vous pensez qu'ils savent brise 10
effectués soit amené à dire à témoigner
de ce qu'ils savent général un mot et
puis on va avancer mais un mot sur un
peu perplexe sur le témoignage de mon
voisin je sais qu'à la villa susini
c'est officiel pendant toute l'année 61
c'était une villa qui était celui par un
service administratif de l'armée de
l'air or notre mot voisins étaient du
train et il n'a jamais eu accès à la
villa susini en 1961 en salle et en
début de série n 2 qu'il appuyait un tri
être introduit
voilà en général qui a vu jour shehata
témoignages écrits d'un militaire qui
m'a dit que c'était la marine à ce
moment là avance bon train tout le
tralala rinaudo banques
l'autre jour peut sortir de bons et on
va vous prêter jusqu'à ce qu'elle savait
rapidement t7 continuer on tourne en
rond avec oui j'ai vécu ça ils ont décru
s'annonce assez passionnant vous n'êtes
pas prêt non mais je vous dis pas
contraire à mes rations qui arrive à des
moyens je ne vous dis pas le contraire
mais ce que je voulais dire il ya deux
choses à mes yeux extrêmement importante
c'est que en 2000 le 31 octobre il ya
douze personnes deux des grands témoins
de sur la question de la guerre
d'algérie comme témoigné qu'ils ont dit
il faut enfin que l'état reconnaisse qui
sait pas pourquoi c'est très important
la souffrance d'henri pouliot mais ces
douze dont je vous parle j'ai parlé avec
eux avant d'élaborer ce texte mais tous
lambel des deux là que vous faites à
l'isr 2001-2002 non 2000 par le talent
octobre sur france inter en direct le
matin aussi bon et madeleine rebérioux
en direct dans l'émission de temps au
lit ça a fait un effet assez terrible
c'est très important parce que les deux
en question ne voulait pas ouvrir ce
qu'ils appellent les plaies de la guerre
d'algérie parce que tout le monde a
souffert de cette guerre les appelait
les militaires les pieds noirs les
algériens d'abord excusé moi bon mais
est donc cet appel était destiné à dire
une bonne fois pour toutes
reconnaissez ce qui s'est passé et ça ça
ne pensera pas les plaies
mais ça mettra à jour cette question un
lionel jospin tout de suite a dit il
faut entendre cet appel et ça a déchaîné
un débat que connais bien sylvie tenu
pendant un an non excusez-moi je
voudrais dire autre chose essayez
aussaresses et puis tout ça un bon là
voilà et non mais cet appel n'a pas été
entendu il ya eu deux sondages
deux sondages de l'opinion publique qui
demandait à ce que la france reconnaisse
qui s'était passé en match d'ouverture
excusez moi mais je vous parce que vous
parlez aussi de l'algérie je voudrais
quand même qu'on puisse faire venir
manica râle qui va nous parler aussi
d'une histoire semblable mais qui
concernait cette fois ci anne algérien
et on bat pour faire une transfusion
écouter un nouvel extrait de
documentaire
cette fois ci c'est quelqu'un qui nous
explique que évidemment tous les
militaires n'ont pas été des
tortionnaires
dans ma famille on peut pas dire que
tous les appelés ont été dé ce
tortionnaire
ce serait une connerie et aucun
historien d'ailleurs qui dit ça on peut
pas dire non plus que tous les
militaires de carrière étaient des
tortionnaires
il ya même des officiers de
renseignement qui ont pratiqué ou
autrement
le renseignement quand tortureront les
gens par contre ce que l'on peut dire
c'est qu'on a mis du matériel des hommes
pour torturer il y avait une institution
qui étaient à l'intérieur de l'armée qui
était face a été même développé par des
colonels enfin je veux dire qu'ils
étaient la contre-révolution voilà voilà
pour cet extrait général beaucoup parce
que pendant les extraits il ya beaucoup
de débats sur ce plateau
merci mme annie caral de nous avoir
rejoints
vous êtes historien de vous aussi vous
êtes à la fois et algériennes et
françaises et même américaine d'origine
et vous avez écrit sur ali boumendjel
qui lui avant maurice audin a connu le
même drame que maurice oda oui en
février 1957 ali boumendjel est arrêté
par les parachutistes et y est détenu
entre les mains des parachutistes
pendant quarante-trois jours avant
officiellement de se suicider en se
jetant du haut d'un des immeubles qui
était occupé par les parachutistes sur
les hauteurs d'alger
billard vous dit officiellement parce
que vous pensez que c'était pas c'est
pas un suicide c'est un assassinat
ce que d'ailleurs de la même façon
qu'avec odin les militants de l'époque
et la famille traduit ce très bien le
langage militaire il parle très bien le
militaire ils savent bien que quand on
s'est évadé on est mort ils savent très
bien que quand on sait quand on s'est
suicidé en réalité on a été assassiné ça
ne fait aucun doute pour pour personne
jusqu'en 2001
la seule version officielle qui existe
est celle d'un est celle d'un suicide
jusqu'au moment jusqu'en 2000 2001
jusqu'au moment où ça reste avoue avoir
s'être occupé de faire assassiner ali
boumendjel en le faisant jeter du haut
de cette de cet immeuble
élodée l'a reconnu on n'a pas de
reconnaissance officielle de ce 2e rené
et moi n'y avait pas moyen âge là qui
qui confirment d'autres sources qu'on
peut qu'on peut trouver également alors
on va les rabots peut-être sur le cette
torture qui ces morts qui ont concerné
je ne sais pas combien d'algériens
à l'époque je ne sais pas non plus
personne ne sait encore une fois sur la
question des chiffres
de deux choses l'une d'abord on n'aura
pas la documentation qui va nous
permettre de compter ni les morts ni les
torturer et d'autre part on en revient à
cette question que comptait pour essayer
de prouver quelque chose n'a pas de sens
d'accord un mot sur les appeler vouliez
parler d appeler 4 se projeter sur
aujourd'hui parce que cette affaire est
incroyablement douloureuses et chaque
fois qu'on fait un débat dessus on se
rend compte à quel point c'est
douloureux à quel point la france
n'arrive pas il s'agit pas tourner cette
page mais de pouvoir la lire plus
sereinement si je puis dire cette page
de son histoire
un mot sur les appeler qui était dans
ses rues des as peur et je n'ai pas
qu'un peu pas qu'un peu c'est un peu
difficile de savoir mais disons qu'en
général on retient à peu près pas de pas
loin de 2 millions de jeunes hommes de
france qui ont été envoyés en algérie
pour faire la guerre je crois que au
delà du témoignage dans le bouillon il
faut dire que
la pratique de la torture en algérie
elle sait réellement disséminés sur
l'ensemble du territoire elle n'était
pas cantonné dans des centres
spécialisés il y avait des centres
d'interrogatoire qui était connue de
tout le monde comme étant des lieux ont
amené des gens arriver et si c'est
accidentel mais elle est inscrite dans
la pratique de la répression et il
pouvait y avoir un jeune berger de 14
ans par exemple arrêter par un bataillon
parce qu'on pense qu'il a vu qu'il sait
des choses et qui tombent entre les
mains de la troupe et qui passe et qui
passe par les gens qu'ils ont arrêtés
dans un petite unité majoritairement
composé d'appeler partout parce qu'elle
avait une espèce de signal qui laisse
entendre qu'on pouvait le faire
je crois que oui on peut parler du fait
qu'il y avait pas de verrou posé en tout
cas y'a pas de verrou pour deux raisons
d'abord il faut dire que la pratique de
la torture en algérie elle est
antérieure à la guerre les services de
police en algérie
ceux des renseignements généraux torture
et bien avant 1954 dans des conditions
qui peuvent leur sembler dont le livre
vidal naquet site une affaire d'un
algérien qui disparaît entre les mains
des policiers en novembre 54 n'a pas dit
un mot
c'est pas pour faire l'équilibré hamon
n'a pas dit un mot non plus sur la
torture pratiquée par le fln mais on n'a
pas produit un mot sur wii cette guerre
qui n'était pas une guerre au départ
mais qui comme une guerre mais sur cette
guerre quasi civile si je puis dire et
dont on se demande si elle ne peut pas
forcément être une geek une guerre sale
ça me dit alors italienne hameau mais
rapide comme au civil m le fln ne
torture pas pour obtenir des
renseignements le fln pratique la
violence oui sur les algériens oui pour
quelles raisons le fln n'existe pas
depuis longtemps c'est un petit groupe
d'hommes qui s'organisent pour lancer
l'action armée dans la nuit du 31
octobre pour une rente 54 ce n'est donc
pas un parti qui a derrière lui une
masse d'adhérents qui vont le soutenir
tout de suite dans l'action qu'ils vont
vite
les maquis cacher les militants et de
cet enfant terrorisé et la violence
jacques tys d'obtenir un soutien
matériel et logistique est absolument
indispensable sans lequel et makeen
survivrait pas est ce qu'on peut
imaginer ce genre de guerre ce genre de
conflit s'était quasiment comment dire
enfin civile sans que ce soit une autre
chose qu'une guerre sale
moi j'aurais tendance à dire que toutes
les guerres sont sains pardonnez moi et
surtout je crois que tu la cavée guerre
avec des camps bien défini des troupes
qui avançaient trop petit recul des
machins mauroy la région c'est la guerre
c'est par hasard que la torture
surgissent effectivement dans ce type de
guerre - je crois que l'élément
fondamental dans cette pratique de la
torture
c'est quand on confie à l'armée des
pouvoirs de police si vous comparez avec
l'irak aujourd'hui ou l'afghanistan
on va le même c'est le même type de
schéma on fait la guerre à une
population et on donne à l'armée des
pouvoirs d'arrestation et de détention
qui lui permettent de tout faire un mot
de chacun
rapidement pour faire rapidement jeu
c'est malheureux de lire ça pour
terminer j'aimerais votre sentiment
avant
c'est un peu facile de dire que vous
êtes vous avez aussi une société
algérienne autant que françaises
qu'elles seraient des attentes
côté français et côté algérien de la
façon de régler entre guillemets cette
histoire là
d'abord un moment il va falloir re dire
ce qu'on n'a pas encore dit bien
clairement ce soir c'est l'impact de la
torture et c'est aussi pour cette raison
là que les chiffres n'ont pas de sens
c'est à dire qu'on va compter le nombre
de personnes qui ont été physiquement
torturé
comment est-ce qu'on va compter le
nombre de personnes qui ont été victimes
de torture immatériel devant lesquels on
a menacé leurs familles qui ont assisté
aux tortures de leur famille torture
psychologique on a pas on n'a pas décrit
le phénomène de diffusion à l'intérieur
de la société de2 de la violence et de
la terreur provoquée par ce qu'on attend
aujourd'hui en algérie et est assez
différent de ce qu'on attend en france
on souffre de cette torture on souffre
aussi de la guerre civile à giroud
algérienne on souffre aussi des
événements qui se sont passés de façon
postérieur on est assez on est assez
comment dire fataliste dans la façon de
dire que cette cette guerre a été
nécessairement violente parce que
c'était parce que c'était une guerre de
libération il ya des événements qui sont
là en france
de culpabilité par rapport à cette
question de mon neveu la torture de
l'armée donc le rapport n'est pas le
même le rapport est très est très
différent on est très choquée par
exemple lorsque jean marie le pen arrive
au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle notamment ses anciennes
victimes sont là tout d'un coup se
sentent obligés de 2,2 témoignant mes
envies les conséquences de la torture
sur un mode beaucoup plus personnel sur
la mode à l'usure mialhe ce qu'elle peut
faire genre elle appelle par la guerre
puisqu'il était là dessus mais bon c'est
son volonté que j'ai déjà un mélange
d'un mot mais rapidement surnom est ce
que sur la question est celle là est ce
que surtout claude fait l'ancien général
le général le vous n en aura envie qu'un
moment eu une parole officiel de l'armée
de l'état sur ces questions là pour vous
libérer peut-être un peu plus s'il doit
y avoir une repentance ne peut pas être
unilatérale et il faut qu'elles soient
bilatérales
c'est le point de vue de nous parler de
repentance ne souhaiteriez dont
certaines aux côtés des deux côtés bon
ceci dit sur l'évaluation de la torture
j'ai fait une recherche dans les
archives d'une de la croix rouge à
genève
j'ai passé plusieurs jours dans les
archers de la croix rouge la croix rouge
avait des délégués en algérie qui ont
fait qu ont visité quatre que plus de 80
de sa dette de 39 ans ici ah bon ils ont
causé ils ont fait 400 comptes rendus de
visites ils ont interrogé les gens dans
les sons de d'interrogatoire et autres
et j'ai fait j'ai fait le bilan j'ai
épluché ses quatre champs compte rendu
et j'en ai tiré l'un la conclusion que
parmi les gens interrogés il y en avait
20 % qui reconnaissait avoir été
torturés et que 80 %
donc je démens totalement cette histoire
de torture généralisée mais je crois pas
que ça a été dit comme ça on n'a pas dit
que c'était assez généralisé on a vu que
ça c'était assez chaud analyse et 6 ne
généralisez c'est un mot campoli le
général massu quelques années avant de
mourir on l'a traité les titres du
talent et un homme que je connais ça
venir côté mathieu gallet pas gaga katy
tortue a mis les gâte quand il reconnaît
la torture
comment ce que je dis là on n'a plus le
temps on n'a pas eu le temps en tout cas
vous dites que ça a été reconnu en son
temps par des gens qui étaient bien au
fait des choses pour le reconnaître a su
lui et donc ne faisons pas que vous
lisez tout à l'heure mais ce mariage
c'est que le jeune qu'un choix secondes
le 21 juin 2007 madame odin josette a
écrit une lettre ouverte à nicolas
sarkozy dont la vie est depuis bientôt
trois ans et demi nicolas sarkozy n'a
pas éprouvé le besoin ne serait-ce que
de lui répondre je ne sais pas ce qu'il
aurait pu lui répondre vous souhaiteriez
et elle souhaiterait avoir cette nuit
quand même quand même merci merci
beaucoup merci à vous tous
on aurait bien voulu continuer bien
davantage de débats malheureusement il
faut il faut sortir là mais ne bougeait
pas il y aura bien sûr l'occasion
d'avoir d'autres débats ici et ailleurs
cette question de l'algérie puisque on
va commémorer les accords d'evian
c'était en mars 62 voilà merci à cécile
siksou qui m'a aidé à préparer ce débat
ne bougeait pas général je vous rappelle
que vous avez notre site internet pour
avant l'émission nous faire part de vos
de vos remarques et caetera et que la
semaine prochaine il en parlera des
rapports toujours très délicat entre
presse et politique et je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine sur public sénat
m